leute ihr habt am ende gesehen diese
scheiß filiale wird geschlossen auch zu
recht hey was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video hallo
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut
leute heute kommt endlich ein video das
sich schon länger in planung haben wir
können es allerdings erst heute umsetzen
wenn ich sollte vorher nicht gemacht
habe und so habe ich ja irgendwann mal
mit dem format gestartet das
schlechteste burger-restaurant dünn
halle an pizza restaurant das hat mir
noch eisdiele und so weiter da ist ja
mittlerweile sehr viele videos gilt von
sehr vielen verschiedenen youtube an die
alle in diese richtung videos machen bei
mir jetzt keiner sagt alex das hast du
aber geklaut nein die idee ist nicht
geklaut das erste video dazu kam von mir
vor über sieben monaten das wollte ich
einfach nur noch mal gesagt haben könnt
ihr gerne abdecken da ging es um den
schlechtesten burger auf jeden fall habe
ich mir heute gedacht wir haben hier um
die ecke auch so eine poststelle und da
ist es oftmals so dass löcher alles so
ein bisschen chaotisch habe ich bin
tatsächlich auch weil man ja oft auch
pakete bekommen dann bin ich nicht zu
hause dann muss ich die dort abholen ist
halt meistens nervig das ist umso
poststellen auf probleme gibt ist ja
glaube ich eben bekannt
und ich habe mir gedacht hey vielleicht
findest du eine poststelle die wirklich
so komplett down down gerettet ist ja
kann man ja so sagen und ich habe erst
einmal recherchiert ich zeige dass
vielleicht gerne auf und wir haben hier
in köln wirklich die am schlechtesten
bewertete poststelle in ganz deutschland
also ich habe verglichen mit hamburg
berlin frankfurt und ich habe nirgendwo
alle gefunden die so schlecht ist kann
sein dass es irgendwo im letzten kampf
einige de nicht schlecht ist aber die
hier ist wirklich am schlechtesten
bewertet und zwar handelt es sich um ich
weiß ich muss ich das zensieren keine
ahnung es hatte sich auf jeden fall um
diese müsste ich nichts an diesen scheiß
egal
diese filiale hier 64 google rezensionen
und einer bewertung von 1,7 das ist
schon wirklich hat schlecht der eine
stellung bezieht sich auf die
freundlichkeit der meisten mitarbeiter
die öffnungszeiten sind unmöglich und
zudem war die filiale in dieser woche
erneut spontan ständig geschlossen auch
heute es kann wirklich nicht sein dass
es einem glücksspiel gleicht eine
geöffnete post vorzufinden
der briefmarke automat ist zudem weist
effekt ergibt kein rückgeld warum ist
der laden eigentlich immer innerhalb der
öffnungszeiten geschlossen aus schickt
jetzt gehe ich ja gleich hin und er ist
zudem ist das wäre ja nicht so gut
leider kann man hier nicht null stellen
vergeben das hätte diese filiale
aufgrund ihrer willkürlichen da ist
diese eine der schlechtesten filialen in
denen ich bisher im paket abzuholen
hatte zum einen ist sie wie schon bei
vielen total unterbesetzt wodurch die
schlange bis raus auf die straße reicht
und ewig dauern blablabla also wir haben
das noch mal gut zusammengefasst
einstellen einstellen einstellen also
hier jagt einstellen den anderen ein
stern
ich habe hier noch sein handy liegen
dass es irgendwie kaputt und das packen
wir gleich mein paket und verschicken
ist und da das ganze film ich natürlich
vielleicht einmal kurz als vergleich das
hier ist hamburg hier ist wirklich keine
filiale die annähernd so eine schlechte
bewertung hat frankfurt habe ich jetzt
auch keine gesehen hat 2,3 er gut ist
halt nicht 17 also ich will eigentlich
auch gar nicht lange lagern wir fahren
jetzt los und ich bin wirklich gespannt
was da auf mich zukommt vielleicht hat
das ding ja gar nicht auf eine story die
mir gerade eingefallen ist und zwar wenn
ich hier diese poststelle denke wie
gesagt ich warte schon wirklich oft und
eine mitarbeiterin die ist da wirklich
einmal richtig genervt und die hat mir
schon zwei mal gesagt also die hat ein
weg ins gesicht gesagt und nach dem
motto dieser job hier ist wirklich so
scheiße ich bin froh wenn ich hier weg
bin
die kündigung habe ich schon eingereicht
und ich musste sogar ehrlicherweise
sagen ich kann sie verstehen weil da
oftmals so viele leute sind die
natürliche paket haben wollen und sie
ist manchmal ganz alleine da
und dann kann sie keine mittagspause
machen und so weiter also bevor man so
sachen dann so richtig schlecht bewertet
sollte man vielleicht erst mal
nachdenken okay wäre es wohl wenn ich in
dieser situation wäre und dort arbeiten
müsste naja egal wir fahren jetzt los
und wir sehen uns gleich im auto jetzt
so leute auf geht's hier habe ich das
handy was ich verschicken will also ich
brauche also ein paket denke ich mal
dran und ich bin wirklich mal gespannt
auf was für mitarbeiter ich verstoße ob
die wirklich den bewertungen gerecht
werden oder ob es vielleicht auch gar
nicht so ist was man natürlich auch mal
sagen muss die leute schreiben eher eine
negative bewertung als der positive also
wenn irgendwas negatives
man kann man in deutschland ja einmal
direkt würde hier müsste es irgendwo
schon sein
leute eigentlich hätte ich die
poststelle gerade schon sehen müssen von
der straße aus habe ich aber nicht jetzt
dich immer wir sehr schlecht aber auch
noch brauchen wir uns heute nicht
gefunden übrigens wir haben gerade 11 41
also es sollte jetzt eigentlich nicht zu
voll sein
ich bin mal gespannt wie es natürlich
aufs handy und sehen uns dann gleich
wieder immer wieder bisschen nervös wie
immer vor diesen videos aber das gehört
dazu
leute ich habe es gefunden darüber und
rein leute ich dokumentiere erst mal
wieder ein bisschen für euch nach
hier bin ich auf jeden fall rein
gegangen wie man sieht das war überhaupt
nicht viel los
glücklicherweise und an sich darf die
erst mal ist ja nett hier
sodann habe ich diese frau gefragt hier
ich muss das handy verschicken
wahrscheinlich brauche ich einfach so
ein paket da für sie meinte schaut auch
da hinten war da kannst du dir aussuchen
an sich total unspektakulär wobei die
auch irgendwie meinte du brauchst
wahrscheinlich die größte es die haben
wir aber nicht mehr ab dann musst du
eines größeren dem habe ich halt m
genommen also ich glaube es muss ja nur
so dann habe ich hier dieses paket wird
zwei euro kauf was man halt
zusammenfalten muss und ich habe blogger
zehn minuten gebraucht bis es irgendwie
geklappt hat indem dingen war eine
beschreibung drin auf dieser
beschreibung sollten klebestreifen
gewesen sein
gerade gehört habt ich habe überhaupt
nichts verstanden diese beschreibung
also da konnte ich nicht vielleicht
neben di hat für mich überhaupt keinen
sinn gemacht keine ahnung ob ich dumm
bin auf jeden fall habe ich dann
irgendwann geschafft was aber vielleicht
noch wichtig ist zu sagen war zu der
zeit der einzige im laden und die frau
gestand auch die ganze zeit an der kasse
und hat mich so beobachtet also man
hätte ja auch mal vielleicht sagen
können hier versuchs doch mal so wenn
man es einmal gemacht hat dann weiß man
wie es geht und ich finde das ist ja
einfach nur kundenfreundlich das dann
halt kurz zu zeigen das richtig gemacht
ja ganz schön kompliziert
ja ja ich weiß mich aber irgendwie nicht
ganz klar aber ist ja auch egal jetzt
hast du im gespräch gerade habe ich ja
gesagt dass ich doch schon kompliziert
fand und jetzt kommt der höhepunkt der
mich richtig aggressiv gemacht hat und
zwar hat sie gesehen dass ich da keine
klebestreifen für verwendet die auf der
beschreibung draufkleben das habe ich
halt auch übersehen
damit ist keine verwirrung entsteht also
es ging mir halt nur darum da sie mich
ja vorher schon beobachtet hat und
meiner meinung nach ganz klar gesehen
hat dass ich total probleme habe und
auch keine klebestreifen verbindet habe
hätte sie mich freundlicherweise darauf
hinweisen können weil dann hätte ich
nicht noch mal das ganze paket neu
eröffnen müssen um an diese scheiß
klebestreifen zu kommen dann kam mir
noch derart paketbote der seine ganzen
pakete ums gebäude bringen muss und die
nicht vorher abwägen kann weil das geht
den regeln nach nicht und in deutschland
man hat regeln einhalten hier kann man
es an meinen blick sehen ja ich war sehr
sauer also wirklich sehr sauer dann habe
ich irgendwie gesagt komm du gehst jetzt
einfach hier kann man dann auch sehen
dass die filiale geschlossen wird leider
leute ich habe das video gerade
geschnitten und ich bin auch wieder ein
bisschen runter gefahren heute morgen
war das halt einfach so diese situation
dass sich das so genervt hat dass sie
wenig geholfen hat während ich da stand
und keine ahnung hatte wie ich das
überhaupt machen soll trotzdem möchte
ich nicht dass es so rüberkommt dass die
filiale komplett schlecht ist meiner
meinung nach war der service auf jeden
fall vorhanden ja es waren drei
mitarbeiter sagt klar in meinem fall
ich weiß nicht ob sie das extra gemacht
hat vielleicht hat sie es auch nicht
extra gemacht mir kam es ja nur so ein
bisschen vor nicht so ein bisschen von
oben herab betrachtet hat so nach dem
motto boards sehr dumm und sich dann
irgendwie zu feiern war mal kurz zu
sagen ihr so geht das weil es ist ja
nicht zu viel verlangt ansonsten kann
ich halt nicht wirklich was ihnen die
filiale sagen sie war offen alter hat
mich das so aggressiv gemacht leute
diese frauen da drin
die hat mich so aufgeregt kennt ihr das
wenn ihr so richtig heiß auf irgendwie
so ein mitarbeiter von irgendeinem
dienstleistung habt ich war locker 25
minuten drin und irgendwann habe ich das
paket hier einfach so mitgenommen weil
also ich meine ich habe mich vielleicht
ist auch nicht so mega schlau angestellt
aber ich wollte auch mal so ein bisschen
ausreizen zu hilfsbereitschaft von deren
seite 0
und diese frau ich hätte gleich
leute ich hab zum ende gesehen diese
scheiß filiale wird geschlossen
zurecht war ich voll und so ich glaube
die anderen beiden mitarbeiterinnen
waren auch echte die ich hatte war die
hat so langsam geregelt der auf mich
auch wenn es natürlich schade ist so ein
heftig depressiven eindruck gemacht
ich weiß nicht wer sich diese zeit
technik hier ausgedacht hat aber ich
habe es erst mal überhaupt nicht
gecheckt habt ihr auch gesehen
vielleicht bin ich was das angeht auch
einfach dumm keine ahnung kann sein dass
das andere menschen besser hinbekommen
ich habe es nicht hinbekommen
ich schaue nach 15 minuten und habe
dieses dumme paket gefaltet die frau das
ganz genau gesehen an staates die man
hilft und dann sieht die ganz genau wie
ich diese klebestreifen packen wir
fahren jetzt nach hause leicht solche
leute wieder zu hause vorbei stehen wie
genau ist eigentlich auf alles auf dem
video seien auf jeden fall hat die genau
gesehen dass ich voll problem aber weil
ich das prinzip dieses kartons natürlich
habe ich die beschreibung gelesen ich
habe es nicht verstanden da konnte man
seitlich sowie seiten einreisen ich
dachte aber das mache ich jetzt wisst ja
nicht weil nachher ist es kaputt musste
man aber machen habe ich aus der
beschreibung aber nicht entnehmen können
und dann gehe ich dahin nach zehn zwölf
minuten hatte ich schön verpackt sagt
demir obwohl ich mir sicher bin dass sie
mich dabei beobachtet hat jetzt müssen
sie aber noch die klebestreifen drauf
tun ich weiß welche klebestreifen ja in
dem paket drin sind klebestreifen muss
ich wieder aufmachen und irgendwann habe
ich gesagt ich komme orders ein hase
guck mal ein baby hase der osterhase
alter das recht klein auf jeden fall
absteigen gesagt hey das ist mir jetzt
zu blöd ich in dieses paket hiermit bis
zwei euro gekostet hat für einen
pappkarton und bin gegangen weil im
endeffekt hatte ich so meine reaktionen
die ich prüfen leute und naja leute es
war denn auch ganz lustig und wie schon
gesagt diese postbankfiliale postfiliale
postbankfiliale keine ahnung was der
unterschied ist liest ewald
wahrscheinlich zu recht
nein ich muss wirklich sagen die anderen
seite also da waren drei
mitarbeiterinnen es war auch nicht voll
die waren echt nett ich glaube nur die
bei der ich war die hatte irgendwie so
ein bisschen hier hat mir gegenüber sehr
sehr wenig hilfsbereitschaft und
kundenfreundliches verhalten gezeigt
gibt nach oben und schreibt auf jeden
fall weitere ideen für weitere parks in
die kommentare
das was mir instagram abonniert den
kanal glock aktivieren haut rein